you
five four three two one two hours of
1-minute chess night King it is number
one versus two oh boy
Kings Indian attack no play with the C
pawn multiple minor piece exchanges yeah
neither side has an issue structurally
you know this structure will look to
negate the Bishop h5 so better Bishop
four black very solid position Queens
off yes there will be no invasion on the
second the rook is going to try to get
active with a five
okay now this fixes these ponds you know
the king will be there in time to stop
Bishop here this was important
at some point before looking to
undermine b6 this is what's being tried
now
yeah breaking down could take with the
pawn this pawn is fast takes the bishop
could return here to stop look at the
time situation under 20 you know - oh
here's the other thing takes bishop here
you could do this mm-hmm yeah that
that's pretty much game over though that
position took forever three to one
advantage this pawn isn't going to be
fast enough and White has a passed pawn
of his own yeah this isn't this isn't
going to go well for 1996 yeah up the
exchange and a pawn one win not paired
up just yet
oh he isn't a game
let me I'll get this sorted out okay
there it is it did come up okay I just
had to be a little bit patient there
Rebecca Harris so this was the first
place guy Carlson Rebecca Harris was in
second when they played in leap chess
titled arena three
in-betweener
Queen takes pawn with check in this pond
oh this is very dangerous for black
like you get in these moves this is big
trouble for the king
this white have time for that mm-hmm I
don't know if why has time to get these
moves in rook on h1 Oh
just dropped a piece yeah I take z3
Bishop's gone on b7 okay I officially
lost count of the material on this one
oh the old rook up and over and got a
watch out this is a serious pawn this is
not just where it's one point rook is
around to safeguard against the Queen
getting here rook is defended the
Queen's are off this Bishop is very good
this should be a number-one priority I
would think that's what black is gunning
for but white is very fast in white is
winning Wow Carlsen threw in the towel
on this one the Maintenon threat and if
rook takes rook rook takes rook mate the
value of that pawn all right that was a
pretty fast loss there yeah 25:25 games
in leech has titled arena 3 where
Carlsen didn't have a loss and he had
his first loss in round two yeah I'll
take a peek at the standings after this
game see where we are
this bishop will struggle black can't
get in any of these pawn breaks the
bishop is dead okay looking to improve
the bishop with c5 White has some space
this may be improving the majors first
and then these slow improvements
he's play first let's read on the bishop
yeah he really couldn't challenge the
bishop just yet because of this and now
Bishop here you could take out the
knight white is making it very difficult
for the bishop to get active so now you
could take out the knight opposite color
bishop so you have to be a little bit
careful as white about the light squares
but this shouldn't be too much I don't
see how black arranges some battery
along this diagonal that would be I
would take a lot of time I don't know if
you could really pull that off this is
trouble now
Queen wants to get on this diagonal time
situation less than 10 for MIG not sure
what Bishop
is about yeah he just wants in there's
not enough time to get this stuff okay
that games over let's just quickly see
what the standings are Carlson is not on
the first page he is not yet in a game
let's see there we go
mud Pro whoo this is a very strong I am
I would not at all be surprised if we
soon see this I am turned GM for this
account for this player Oh
Bishop pair this Knight is a tough guy
White has some space on the queenside
Knight can be flushed at any moment now
this pawn will be hunted down won't it
hmm yeah he's gonna he's gonna track
this pawn down the knight could take
he's there in time to stop a fork this
is an excellent piece hmm this position
can be brought into question though
f4 close by this Queens getting very
active you know look up and over will be
shot down with this move Bishop offsets
the knight Knight is much better than
whites Knight here he's dropping it
Queen was on that point yeah this one's
over yeah just up a piece now
yeah just keep pushing could always
force the Queen's off
apiece this one's this one's in the bag
alright that game is over standings
Carlson is not yet on the first page
because of that early slip he's in 21st
place plenty of time to catch up however
oh I could also look at these here
forgetting so Carlson is is in 24th and
he's playing the 22nd ranked guy in the
tournament an FM on board not the most
testing of lines that white is playing
here but you don't need to just get a
playable position looking to remove the
master defender of the Kings side and
now a space invader pond it's gonna be
anchored in there so this this structure
really does a number on controlling
three white minor pieces and this is
going to result in a huge attack against
the White King White has the time for
this kind of stuff or the more direct
stuff he's going through with f4
stopping a knight move first demote one
of the pieces no doesn't want to
exchange there this Bishop is ready to
be dead for for game over f3 or the
bishop now this is a passer White's
gonna look to transfer like this or even
slip in here once this night is on f5
this is going to be big trouble queen g5
keeping pressure on something this
Knight is a very clumsy piece and feels
like just a few moves away before black
wins this one
white already asked to give up some paan
I think night there was a move as well
hitting the Queen defending here maybe
not
Queen check it always get the Queen's
off black is up a piece this is too much
two nights for coming in here Queen here
yeah throw on the temple
that's a pick your favorite variation at
that stage okay
well pretty fast pairing he does stay
over 3,000 and he's now in 10th place I
believe he is on streak so wins here
we'll give him four points space c5 is
now watched over and the rook is on to
the line of fire that Bishop is a killer
rook is it clean exchange or not
Queens are gone and in the end this is
the point that white will look to sue me
black will look to target
to structure thing white has better
bishops and something to bite against c3
so now this is something he five is
under attack by both minors Bishop can't
go too far king h2 before the bishop can
go elsewhere and now these pawns are
being targeted and I believe they're
soon to fall yeah no you can't take that
just yet how do you track c4 pawn down
Wow efore just fell two knights versus
two bishops but thing here is the
structure still close to falling hmm
we're gonna have some trades here Bishop
takes rook takes and now c5 exchanging
an unhealthy for a completely healthy
pawn or are you hmm
you get away with that yeah that was a
nice sequence there Night vs Bishop both
sides of the board still relevant white
is the better side here and white has
some time whoo this is gonna be tough
yeah this is this is much better for
team white Bishop could negate the
knight Kings gonna step over and now oh
he's picking up that pond so yeah now
Carlsen is better or excuse me the night
just got trapped yeah he might he might
still be able to win here or not win
draw I should say King here and then a
push but there are these little tricks
where ooh
yeah he's being sneaky there okay I draw
I was gonna say there's these these
positions where if you just have a
bishop but your opponent has a pawn as
well there's still those little if it's
possible that you could still win if you
just have a bishop you could still win
the game as long as your opponent has
like a pawn anyhow we're back into a
game a draw on board so he's he's still
in 10th place will see the stand oh just
drop the Queen that's rough
this is a quick resigner no no quick
resigner here playing on out of momentum
no okay
game over let's see the standings he's
in 14th so a loss and early loss and a
draw clever tactic but fail it is a
player okay not in a game just yet
clever tactic but fail is a new account
hmm okay mark the spark is the next
opponent for Carlsen we still have a lot
of time to go all right some simple
setup looking for a dark square bishop
exchange yes so what's the King's what's
his home going to be where's the home
with all these pawns moved on the Queen
side this is not a happy shelter and you
can't go Kings side because of the
control over FA no castling this is just
getting crunched oh boy oh boy close to
mate yeah it's gonna be mate mate on f7
that was a quick one
where does that put him up to seventh
place at 16 he does have fire first as
in has 31 points whoo
who is this first-place guy I am
loveless versus Carlson now okay this is
a sensitive point c5 versus d3 apply a
little pressure there do it with the
bishop as well or night there was
threatening the e4 pawn that was missed
so up upon and safer King Queens still
on the board yeah
even offered the Queen exchange like
Carlson did queen c6 queenie for g3 is
under fire this night is out of bounds
need to get him back into play now
looking to do that soon there we go it's
a hanging rook maybe a mouse slip yeah
they probably wanted to go to the
seventh ranked the little mouse lip it's
all it takes game over clever tactic has
not slipped up
flawless not even a draw and here we go
the number one guy in the tournament
clever tactic but fail who is this
clever tactic but fail hmm any guesses
it's tough to take a peek at the chat
while I'm uh I'm trying to pay
in this game or out of this tournament
but uh any any idea who you think clever
tactic but fail is even material this is
a nice and Bishop ok he's now down upon
it's right here to take the knight and
the Bishop uncomfortable pin oh wow
that's nice
after a couple exchanges here that you
don't have time to take on this square
well how is this working out now black
is still safe here
what is night before about Wow night
before was he trying B for maybe it was
a mouse lip that's the only thing I
could come up with instead of night
before he was trying to play b4 yeah I
don't think you play night yeah that's
that must have been a mouse lip
well that's a second hit he's at 20 now
clever tactic book fail out of nowhere
starting at 1500 a new GM okay we're
still we're back in here macro next
opponent oh this is this is cool this is
really cool you got we got some
competition for sure a competition for
uh for Carlson in that first place this
this guy that guy was on a tear is on a
tear Wow is he not just dropping a piece
what is going on with the doctor a queen
versus two rooks and a knight not
looking good White has the coordination
just get rid of the dark square bishop
have a new square for the King this
one's not going well you know the King
has King is completely safe yeah rook
here next
this is gonna be resigned unless there
is there Perpetua
he has to step up huh okay he's getting
away with he's gonna be able to stop the
perpetual checks resign another loss for
carlson clever tactic but fail no losses
ten games 10 wins Carlson's back in
another game against now night king 96
who this is very interesting okay a lot
of space here
Queen d4 Queen d3 d4 Bishop d3 trying to
get an e-form think Queen is hit it's a
little bit annoying is it not gonna win
upon their going too fast I couldn't
keep up with what just happened there
you stay on this diagonal he once he
once made on g7 he says take me I want
to give mate here hit the rook what else
to know how to improve for white battle
move yeah this isn't necessary
to guard the night but rather provide a
square for the king this isn't this is
not a threat time edge g3 is is gone
where to go with the Queen here hmm
chase the night away here and then this
get in the Queen's out keep the Queen's
defend the rook Queen takes oh okay here
we go this rook up and over this bishop
is out of the ballgame
not contributing less than 10 seconds
for 1996 mate threat can't really defend
it Queen there rook takes rook he
realizes that resigns take a quick
glance at the top of the board 43 is in
first
22 for Carlsen clever tactic but fail
okay another game now against opera look
at this score 18 to 0 against upper oh
my god those of you who have played
against opera know this is just an
incredible record 18 oh I don't know I
think they're all bullet or hyper
bullets anyhow that's just crazy but I
believe Black has control over this
position even though the record isn't so
great this is a fine position this pawn
does a good job of negating both nights
rook is a little bit active there is a
threat against the bishop why is that
not defended I thought Bishop to b7 was
necessary hmm okay nineteen oh and a a
fast pairing yosef very strong FM
okay caro-kann with this e takes f3
variation you know I find this variation
you could definitely rattle off a lot of
moves fast for black he's just going in
for a quick sacrifice Wow
the Queen will be very invasive there I
doesn't even want to take back looking
for made on g2 in a quick resigner and
with that where the standings 28 with
fire clever tactic but fail is still
perfect who could that be those of you
that are subscribed okay we have a we
have the the battle here what number one
versus number two in the tournament
Queens gambit declined
Wow okay dark-squared bishop Sargon
let's see how the structure changes G
for rook G one looking to peel open the
G file here we go
you get greedy no no time for that
here comes the Jeep on Bishop f5 yeah
down upon now Carlson is down upon but
the knight is under fire rook c8 the
night I believe has to return here to
block off the C file what do I know
he's probably calculating this I'm gonna
see how that works okay King needs to
get off the file Knight is getting
chased around and I save the pawn now
he's trying to hunt down the knight
probably take the knight out I think
this is a pretty strong piece whoo look
at this monster of a knight 27 seconds
blushing the Queen away here here and
then maybe post up on this square minor
pieces are gone g7 is now under fire
this pawn is rolling is it going to
continue to roll I don't know how this
one's gonna play out
look at this black is completely on his
back foot too dangerous
but this is this has to be a number-one
priority okay and he's gone well look at
the clock situation
side passer white is the better side
here is the queen around defending the
pawn and defending the back rank watch
out for Queen here check might have
repetition
repetition no he's gonna pick off of the
pond the King's gonna get chased no he's
not back ranked mate whoa the first loss
for a clever tactic but fail
it only took Wow 13 games 13 games for
clever tactic but fail 13 wins in a row
crazy okay back back in there Carlson is
still in second place Jesse Pinkman I am
opponent next that was a coin flip of a
game whoever is clever tactic but fail
oh man I hope to seem just sit back and
be just as confused as those of you here
Oh
watching those pair that pairing Wow ah
I was I was guessing how that one was
going to end I had no idea how it would
turn out okay what's going on here it's
a little bit more calm compared to that
last game at major piece game structure
and a fork beautiful commentary
structuring a fork I just learned
something ok black set material and
offers a queen exchange beautiful Oh
Knight g5 I guess you have to play up
six right mm-hmm sneaky Queen is here
the bishop is here guarding all the
important squares rook takes rook and
there's mate that's why you can't take
four rook takes rook you're not going to
do this probably could still do that
this is a win
very nice in-betweener this is gonna be
mate King here rook takes rook on push
take here and then take the rook next
for me okay a pretty quick win the
warning is next Carlsen is in second
quick glance 51 for first 36 for Carlsen
tournament standings Wow okay a little
bit of space this is what captures my
attention first this guy here he can be
maintained possibilities for a King side
attack so we have pieces converging over
here already and watch out for the both
bishops working on adjacent diagonals
right towards the black King coupled
with the knight a lot of squares are
under control here by the white camp
picking off upon this does give black a
nice square to work with so up upon but
it's tough to get them rolling this
Knight is fantastic so still looking for
something maybe mmm this is a problem
rook here there's f6 hitting the Queen
and hitting the bishop so that's why we
didn't have rook there this is trouble
I'd prefer black here Knight here and
next there could be a capture this is
going to be reason No
hmm as a perpetual at least no no what
am I talking about perpetual it's up a
piece this pawn is just too far away
this is going to be a win for the
warning
Carlson is also down on time 18 seconds
yeah there's no way to get the King
involved keep this pawn right here and
it boxes out the King a resign for
Carlson he was at 3,000 won rating but
no longer has fire 36 points first
clever tactic but fail is at 53 clever
tactic but fail is still in a game so I
do not believe we'll have that pairing
you're Meyer next opponent or Carlsen
Wow
let's see Catalan is this I believe this
is like one of your buyers main York
Meyers main openings the Catalan looking
to control this pond advance if you can
yeah he's gonna use man that Carlson has
managed to exchange off the 4c pawn and
actually turn out on up let's see how
this is converted give the pawn back but
now the rook is super active we'll get a
pond yeah this will be a very difficult
one for Meyer Meyer to hold in bullet
rook takes so the rook is going to play
the role of defending the pawn from the
side not the front he could have he
could have gone here and then this would
still that idea of guarding from the
side but okay he switched the position
of the rook
so here there'd be this white should
keep this pawn here I believe yeah what
it what does black do here because there
this is you know this is tough this is
just a little time thing I believe King
I don't know what kind of progress the
king can make I think he's going to just
yeah waste and try and burn some time
and then come over here and then try
something else and this is something
else playing that rook they're just in
time when the King wasn't on g2 to pick
up the H pawn yeah so now now we got
some more time burners if you want well
there goes upon this is this is simple
now I'm gonna play it out apparently
well Carlson is under six seconds but
he'll manage
and mate okay with that win 59 clever
tactic but fail 41 for second carlson is
in at third
I'm not sure where it was right around
the half hour point well actually I do
know Carlson was definitely in first in
Lee chest titled Erina 3
after a half hour of play you still have
one hour 28 minutes to go first place
prize 2,250 bucks
second is fifth is a 500 okay yeah
their first game that these guys had
minier ended up winning as a as a
painful checkmate at Carlson fell form
he'll look back on that if you're
curious anyhow what's happening here up
the exchange Carlsen strong piece yeah
but the exchange is the exchange here
all white pieces will be playing yeah
this pawn is now gone this is big
trouble this will not end well for team
black see how it's converted ooh that's
how it's converted you know and I said
let's see how it's converted I was
thinking okay do you double up on the
seventh rank
no you just it's checkmate in one you
just give me get the game over with
eldest 64 is next a new one of the newer
GM's I am turn GM recently now right
isolated on position opposite sides
Castle position offer of a queen
exchange Queens will stay on board right
cleanest it I guess the G file at some
point no addressing the night position
where is he gonna go by the way he's out
of squares it is a he the night is short
on squares that poor beep on is no
longer around helping support the night
yeah this
is covered enough queen and night have
it clock is going away you don't even
have to take the night just yet there we
go yeah get on the G file capturing it
now what do you do to defend this point
nothing doesn't mind wants to take the
night out and Oh woo now that's that
scary though bishop check the King
stepped up it'd be mate this probably
got a bit more tactical than Carlson
would have liked he's prepared to give
up the Queen now for a capture here yeah
he'll find safe ground
he's got the minor pieces around and a
boatload of time this Knight is a master
defender and I'll see you mating that
here yeah Mike it made it even the white
king this is a time thing
three seconds pork that's gonna do it
white resigned before his flag fell
where do we stand
63 clever tactic but fail only loss was
against Carlsen 44 Carlsen still has a
lot to do a lot to go to catch first
place clever tactic but failed just
finished the game I think we're getting
that pairing and we are Oh God Oh twenty
nine ninety four versus 2985 who is this
do they have it in the notes oh boy okay
No
nothing going on with the structure this
is a minor piece major this is a piece
play position light square for white
could get the night if you want it let's
that move about fancy pawn takes pawn
takes taking advantage of this Bishop
Knight moves Bishop takes Bishop and the
knight is saying you know I'm going to
take something down you're not just
getting this piece back for free white
is okay now it is its balance material
this night should be fantastic though no
get them on d5 black still does not have
a flight square just yet I would prefer
white here supergluing the knight in
with e4 to be a little bit careful you
do give up the d4 square white offers a
queen exchange why it says no way I keep
the Queen's on hunt down you're a pawn
but this guy might bolt at any moment
Bishop is under fire that's defended the
a pawn is gone and now he's passed to
past pawns on the Queen side getting
right behind just in time so the rook
isn't able to support it he wants this
just in time also let's not forget about
a check and a mate that's the bigger
issue I always hunt down this pawn this
is this should be a win for team ye and
it's going to be with these two threats
Oh managed managed to find a way F for
trying to loosen this up yeah a clock
situation is in White's favor this rook
is enormous yeah and now sneaking in
mate right around the corner
more like resign yes resigned time so
another win in the Drunken Stein versus
clever tactic but fail match 48 for dr.
drunken Stein 67 that's a huge win he's
now back only 19 points 19 points is a
lot in any of these guys yeah just like
any of these guys could still knock off
Carlsen I mean look at the last game
they played not in this tournament
but is a three to one so a guerrilla is
certainly capable of knocking off
Carlson again let's see what happens
efore is central now let's look at the
positional features first tactics b6 was
a problem
96 white is up the exchange that'll be
but a bit more general here White's up
the exchange things are gonna change so
fast oh man yeah
these Knights are without comfortable
homes and the Queen cannot move and
defend the rook so the rook is gonna
fall black says Uncle Rebecca Harris
currently up for three Rebecca Harris is
in 8th place
Carlson is now over 3,000 let's see what
happens here
ok Bishop is on a very good diagonal I
like White's position here converging on
this square is the knight gonna get hit
now what's happening here Oh an
in-betweener it's getting sharp now with
these last couple of moves now here here
there is Queen takes pawn Wow
ok I guess this is the idea have the
King act as a block hater but white is
gonna sweep right in this is not good or
Carlsen not good yeah and that's why we
have a huge pause here there isn't a
there isn't a good move he's gonna try
to hunt this pawn down well there isn't
a rook move here the bishop is defending
that but there are these discoveries the
bishop could go here and after King here
there is some bishop move that's what
white was calculating just then I
imagine and he's got all of his pieces
swarming around the King who cannot
castle in either direction ok this
right here seals off this truck but
there's still these killer bees around
try and do something I can't double up
just yet hmm
push it's evening out on the clock this
is a big game right here and it tried
enough not like that oh boy
let's check me folks Carlson goes down
5-3 is the match score between those two
and a very fast pairing now against pop
G Wow down to 29 90 week
unbelievably week 2990 okay let's see
structure symmetrical see file play I
don't know if you could really do
anything with the Queen here I don't
know how much of an inconvenience no now
there are things that are annoying for
white to defend both of these are under
fire yeah there goes one of them and
yeah the Queen side is basically
collapsing now Queen exchange is fine up
upon and some more yeah there's gonna be
an uncomfortable pin night here yeah
chop and a chop here through the towel
let's see where we are at on the leader
board clever tactic but fail is still in
first with 69 right in second is Carlson
with 54 not in a game just yet one hour
and 18 minutes to go for this arena
nirvana 95 next opponent ranked 22 in
the tournament let's see we get here -
oh is their match score
okay what was that start it must have
been an exchange Slav I wasn't looking
away at the chat there for a second okay
now
just a simple structure and a watch out
for a fork b6 how to defend this
normally you would like to play here
queen is in the way you know you know
black is finding it uncomfortable to
deal with this night to be six move yeah
no not really what you want to do
woo okay this is not a fun piece for as
long as this night now that night is
extra tricky why square time do you
defend with the Queen okay that's the
flight Square multi-purpose King here
maybe use this pawn as a way to weaken
the King side structure meanwhile this
pawn is collapsing I don't think yeah I
also wouldn't been able to manage a way
to keep the Queens on the board Carlsen
goes down again okay is that 54 clever
tactic but fail also slipped up a game
yeah a couple games Rebecca Harris
knocked off clever tactic the feel here
we go again
two two one is there man scored number
one versus number two guy huge game
right here
well done there there are bigger games
but uh yeah cuz neither player has fire
at this point
Roy Lopez light square bishop exchange
c3 these guys are playing so fast and so
good mmm okay this is a loose piece it's
targeting a a six-night could be
targeted at any moment he is right now
just gonna build up on this yeah the
knight needs to move and black wants to
cover c7 this is an excellent knight on
f3 I love that piece Wow
what just happened there okay some
exchanges on the a and B file mmm taking
advantage of the
pin tough to defend this is getting
broken down for black now gonna pick up
a pawn that's not just any pawn now this
gives it and the knight a wonderful
square on e5 rook feels a little no
that's a pretty it's a pretty good piece
has a lot of lateral movement why not
take the pawn there okay the rook is
under fire
Knight is hanging rook is hanging bishop
saying what's not hanging look at the
clock two to one rooks gun Queen here
there's Queen takes bishop white is up
the exchange looking to push through
with g5 now the night is under fire
Queen takes pawn mm-hmm
maybe Queen here give up the night no
save the knight defend the poem watch
out for f2 matin - threat defends the
second rook is hit evening out on the
clock Queen exchange this night it's
ready to get into f4 oh boy
mate threat on g2 its mate white
resigned before black key give checkmate
their match score is now two two black
wins
okay so desmond and that's the second
loss a noble in a row 71 54 is where
carlson is at stels a lot of work to do
clever tactic but fail is in a game
against Rebecca Harris at the moment the
warning is the next opponent for Carlsen
hmm
this is who
Alston was playing before the tournament
began I guess as a bit of a warm-up okay
night versus Bishop ending slightly
better king position for white but this
is quickly changing this is a perfect
structure for black nice home for the
king light square not sure why he's
going over here
ah the knight wants to occupy that
square got it
yeah this is this is a fine structure
and there really isn't a better spot for
the night
I don't know how white makes progress in
this position meanwhile what are you
doing about this pawn yeah you have to
give up the bishop for night at this
stage and black is the better side this
isn't a poor structure in this
particular ending black controls the
only opened fire fire black controls the
only open fire oh man
where did fire come from is somebody on
fire I'm not on fire neither as drunk
it's done he's looking to get on fire
this pawn is gonna be picked up but this
rook is gonna get very active pac-man
mode once he's here gonna go for a
repetition repetition it is it's too
scary to allow this okay so I guess he
gets a point for that one point he's no
longer in second even 58 is in second
MSB - no idea who that is
anyhow nirvana 95 won the last time so
what do we have a Benko gambit accepted
this is fun let's see him playing this
one too much this opening see how quick
he rattles off the moves here leaning on
b7 keeps an eye on this structure is
also opposite the king now playing with
f5 giving up some squares just to peel
open the F file may be trying to
converge on f2 one day sacrifice
[Music]
during first he wants out the king okay
yeah as mentioned giving up a very nice
square here but black has some squares
as well to work with well there oh this
is trouble for who though okay this is
trouble for white now only once it got
to that point that I realized yeah
like is now up the exchange this pawn
gonna be dangerous if why cannot do
anything with the a pond it's a it's
going to be difficult yeah this night
could always be around to defend can he
be challenged though if he challenged
with this but he could drop in here
there he goes whoa hang on you could be
challenged once more no I have to give
that check with the bishops somewhere
yeah it's gonna have to give up the rook
but look at these poems I like black
five pounds versus the knight position
they're moving so fast okay yeah look at
that
take my pawn Ike Wien yeah they're
pushing through this night too many jobs
for the night yeah five pawns versus the
night
not gonna it's not gonna happen team why
also the clock as well okay resigns
Carlson got that one and is now at 57
first place 74 17 points behind really
have to string some wins together one
hour ten minutes to go ali reza 2003
next opponent english oh ok not a
capture on d5 huh so this is taking in a
Benoni structure pushing through on the
queenside yeah this is a very simple
structure easy to play fast moves here
for white it's gonna give up the bishop
in the end this is a very weak bond I
don't see how it ever exchanges itself
off or let's say the C pawn and if it
falls the C pawn becomes past it's a
very nice structure for the white side
one pawn island of six
get away with this chase the rook away
take the knight and then take b7 b7 is
just gonna go down this is gonna be the
exchange Bishop takes b7 there we go
or is it no their queen was unprotected
but white is up upon its going to add
has the bishop pair not true well bow
both sides had the bishop pair some
space for black but definitely for
choice white is for choice being up upon
and trading down some I don't like to
get him playing this night could use
some help
how'd he get him playing getting kettled
knights normally not not such a good
thing wasn't this this was played a
little bit too fast setting this pawn
he's gonna drop now here it could be
captured and this is under control now
okay now black is for choice space this
night is very clumsy he's been clumsy
for some time you know he got a little
bit too aggressive with the C pawn too
early too aggressive too early
Knight is under controlled by the bishop
offering a knight exchange no thanks and
I look for a dark square Bishop exchange
and then sink the knight in here might
have a little bit back and forth I think
Carlsen wants more in this case being up
just a hair on the clock going for the
dark square Bishop exchange and now a
knight here no lack is tiny bit better
black is now up upon but this is gonna
be a rat race let's see three point
seven seconds yeah it's gonna get a fork
no don't take the pawn don't take the
pawn if you take the pawn it's a draw if
you don't take the pawn you could try to
burn the time that's why he's not taking
the pawn time out white wins this is one
of the one of the rules it is still
possible
you know this pawn could come down turn
into a bishop and then there's ways to
give mate when it's a knight versus
Bishop position anyhow we got another
very clever very clever to not take that
pond there Joerg meyer next opponent I
missed the beginning I blinked at the
beginning of this game this must have
been some well exchanged French one way
or the other
let's see
this is a very nice square i like blacks
position a lot black is better here
these nights are ideally placed here
here where's the night going he just
doesn't want to even allow the bishop to
take the night and I like to target that
yeah there there wasn't a rook here move
but have this and he's challenging the
strong knight Knight takes Knight
there's first Rick takes rook rook takes
pawn and only then a recapture and there
we have it
King steps up going back you just get in
the rooks way white is now up upon and
is gonna pick up some more how do you
want to do it want to take here defend
the base point a pawn is now running
wild 90 is under control fiend keto
denied no good here comes the a pond
he's super quick King f4 king e5 and
pick your favorite way to do it yeah
what you don't get made it here there
will be no mate
giving up the bishop that might have
been just one of those you know let me
just flush the King back I kid as long
as my King isn't can get mated I'm cool
probably still winning as well but yeah
this position is a win for white that a
pawn is too much okay
back in another game quick glance here
clever tactic but fail a tea with fire
Carlson has 63 with fire still 17 back
in advanced
advanced variation of the caro-kann
light with some space what
better bishop a very strong night okay
this is blacks worst peace taking away
from the center wants something along
this file so first stopping Knight to g5
and only then castling castling first
Knight g5 that would be forcing a very
weakened reply by black and this is
trouble or Carlson
oh yeah yeah you don't have to budge
with the night that's gonna be mate oper
with his first win against carlson ever
nineteen to one big loss for carlson he
was on fire
clever tactic but fails in first is he
in a game he must still be in a game
that is he may have been in a game
anyhow we do not have that one versus
two pairing
we will be having more of those pairings
but not right now okay Carlson is in
third twenty two thousand two hundred
fifty bucks for first place Wow okay
this is a weak bond Mike's gonna White's
gonna put some pressure on it and a
fallin out there we go
queens are off this should be easily
converted for white see how this is done
step by step bishop controls the night
Knights gonna be challenged hmm okay
tough to really get more active here
with the white pieces take it back over
here might want to try a three preparing
to meet a four with be for this punky
get pretty deep
this Knight is annoying okay well now
the knight is challenged this King can
maybe start to get a little bit active
yeah
King is way active way more active in
the black King wow that's a very passive
move grabbing the beep on
some checks in here Bishop is hit there
are no mates here for black there goes
the night okay that's a win
black resigned where we at here clever
tactic but fail is in a game against op
ER doctor drunken Stein's at 65 MSB to
no idea who that is at at 74 pop G next
opponent okay things didn't go well last
time for pop G focusing on a weak point
C form with the night and now the other
night flush him away and then jump in
now I'm just gonna give up the bishop in
order to grant the knight access to c4
he's gonna give him a shove okay so
these guys gonna get oh whoops
oh he's going in for that that was an on
purpose giving up the Queen for a minor
piece and a rook number one priority
stay coordinated for black down a queen
here White's going hunting hmm Bishop
takes Knight is met with matin - careful
white careful white I probably would
have fell for that okay and now this is
easy for black I imagine being up a pawn
and even on the clock maybe not so easy
and he's gonna he's gonna go hunting
that that rook is flying now this guy's
a runner on take you take with check and
you cannot stop that pawn will have
resignation right now
there we go back to tournament land
where do we stand a tea with fire clever
tactic but fail is in a game against
Uruguay 67 with fire
88 with fire first no game just yet
Carlson is back 21 points and is now in
a game against
go Kirk on I am go Kirk on ok first time
they are playing this is probably a fun
experience for go Kirk on who is also
streaming let's see there goes the heart
the queenside structure and in exchange
but it's getting one back this is a
structure thing light will have an
easier time targeting the weak points
here there's a fork and if here the
knight gets to enjoy the d5 square for
forever and that's what's going to
happen this is a weak point the knight
is challenged where is he going
I was getting a little bit to be a
little bit careful no no not quite there
is no way to trap the night oh he's
looking for these tricks
he's got more tricks taking advantage of
the pin Bishop here f4 bishop here I
believe na here and then King here
tricky I'm just gonna anchor in the rook
he's up to clean pawns I will get to
those of you I was trying to say it
earlier when the game's popped up very
fast those of you who are subscribing
her throwing bits my way and such I will
address all those at the end of this
tournament but we still have 58 minutes
to go let's see how this finishes up
less than look at the time difference 32
seconds to 7 seconds that was a big win
drunken stein is on fire but so too is
clever tactic but fail 92 76 71
Carlsen's back in a game what did we
miss that
some Catalan the rook is gone okay
space here I'm gonna pick off another
pond there was Bishop here oh he's
dropping a bishop that wasn't planned or
was it rook is dead oh that's beautiful
I love that oh man
their first time playing that's very
tricky Queen takes pawn rook takes
Bishop Queen here and uh where's your uh
where's your ruck going it's cooked
could do some Oh bishop there is Bishop
takes pawn King takes Bishop Knight here
Queen is a gunner Knight there anyhow
Bishop here threatening me so fancy King
takes Queen in the corner mate Bishop
takes pawn Knight takes pawn Knight
takes pawn ways check the rook is gun
Queen takes pawn check next this is game
over white resigns pretty fast win
probably just about a minute for that
game but clever tactic but fail is still
on fire with 96 maintaining a good 20
point lead over Carlsen all right we do
not have that pairing let's see if each
of each of them can keep the fire very
interested to know who this clever
tactic but fail is who could it be all
right I prefer white here because of the
pawn this space that black has is now
being challenged and he could be flushed
away at any point as well okay rather
open up the B file the Knights are
competing for d3 yeah white is now
coordinating well with this this pawn
yeah now the structure a very nice
structure for white one pawn restricting
these to white is basically up upon as
all the base points covered the night
covers d1 little flight square no that
was probably more than a flight square I
guess huh h3 for g4 King up and then
it's something on the
file now he's transferring on the B file
quiz she can know this once a queen
exchange
yeah Queen exchange and now maybe
reposition the knight that's what we
have looking at the d5 square now
hanging onto the pond now push them
Bishop takes there's rook takes here now
undermining the structure Knight g4 and
right around the corner here comes a
five this could be captured this pawn is
going to go down pretty even on the
clock and now this guy falls doesn't
want that wants the c5 pawn hmm all
right
White has a wonderful night strong night
versus very poor Bishop and make sure
the King is not cut off that's why he
stepped up and now we have a technical
position more active rook much better
minor piece and much better on the clock
better for Carlsen winning for Carlsen
unless there's some quick mate there is
no quick mate though this pawn falls the
King could escape time out for team
black another win for Carlsen 100 points
for clever tactic but fail drunken Stein
is now in second I think we're going to
get that pairing
no we're not close
I thought neither player was in a game
just then MSB to next opponent
um I blinked how did that pong get dry
no it's not it's not a pond advantage
what am I talking about okay now it is a
pond advantage black is up a pond black
is up two ponds no this queen is an
extra Carlson is somehow up a queen
basically yeah up up a queen not a clean
for like a couple minor pieces just a
queen and me okay that was a fast one I
don't know what happened there here's
your here's your quick preview of the
queen fall yeah that's how it fell
ninety-four into d2 anyhow gonna get
another game here where the standings
one hundred clever tactic but fail
slipped up and is in a game against
night King meanwhile we now have dr.
drunken Stein versus Rebecca Harris this
is a huge game throwing the H pond down
very fast very early connecting Knights
now okay so this is the idea focus on
the light squares some where's the Kings
home going to be now that the rook has
played here this is a huge game being
able to go up four points when the
number one guy is not on fire Bishop is
now defending now rip takes there's
Bishop takes pawn with check and then
Queen takes rook might do this just to
make sure these pawns staple stay a
split no just going to secure the b5
point so what's the what's the plan here
that was oh that was very interesting
maneuver right then Wow so the knight is
prepared to block you could throw in the
check at any moment right now the knight
must block
hmm a 1 and the bishop okay the king
move the rook is defended there aren't
any good checks this is game over night
I say the queen is hit white I'll be
able to convert this and most important
thing
King security this will be resigned very
soon I imagine where's the where the
mates still no good checks or black mate
threat for black watch you don't mouse
slip yeah this is good this is going
down soon could I always get the Queen's
off with Queen f4 time advantage as well
up a bishop and two pawns not the not
the best conversion going on right now
but this pawn is fast yeah five seconds
okay now he's gonna play it out right to
the end made on g1 who okay where we at
in the standings 102 to 87 only a
15-point gap 50 seconds to go 50 seconds
ago 50 minutes and call it 50 seconds 12
teen is in fifth place which is amazing
fantastic player 12 team very strong nm
okay how are things looking in this game
not really a fan of this Bishop hmm well
this is difficult for team black this
Bishop is not contributing how do you
get out of this pin
as Carlson get out of this pin that's
how Bishop takes theirs Knight takes
with check ok this rook is officially
dead
it will never move black knows this the
Queen sweeping in next the rook will be
plucked and that's it black resigns
pretty quick win 39 seconds 47 seconds
remaining and clever tactic but fail
slipped up he's at 102 meanwhile Carlsen
has fired is at 91 i am ali reza 2003
next opponent 2987 i might have to take
a quick peek to see what a Carlson's
performances after this game right here
if I remember okay so some indirect
pressure being applied to d5
structure designed to negate the bishop
black could take out the bishop here but
okay that would allow the building up in
the center some play on the F file
that's what we have this night could be
challenged I like a knight move okay
there we go
this is hit though hmm can't defend that
a little bit uncomfortable okay I think
he's gonna he's gonna go for that Wow
okay opposite color Bishop position
white is the better side here yeah white
is the better side because white is up
to pawns not looking good and I don't
think there's anything happening here
this is too strong of a structure this
would be an impressive one to see
Carlsen come back from yeah wants to
keep the some material on so that
there's still some tactics White has to
be on the lookout for a capture here and
then this but black is aware of that one
tactical idea that's why the rook is
patrolling the third-ranked White's
gonna black is trying to get active with
the King but you can't get too active
you might end up get made getting mated
somehow
even on the clock less than 20 seconds
for each side this is good news for
black if
a whole black resigned King takes rook
and there was going to be a fork okay
big game right here Carlson with that
loss does not have fire but the biggest
pairing right now
number two drunken Stein versus clever
tactic but fail what is this a Catalan
another Catalan hmm we saw the Catalan a
lot in the candidates tournament a fork
is avoided with E 5 Queen is getting off
of that file and minor piece battle
Carlson could get a night here and he is
going to get a night there it's a
problem for clever tactic but fail
strong knight on d5 oh I thought I
thought pawn takes was something to
seriously consider huh
the pawns would be weak but the knight
wouldn't be able to stand on d5 anymore
at some point f4 not just yet I guess
get the rooks out so right around this
point if rook takes there's pawn takes
yeah
and now the knight needs to find a new
home ooh does he there's no pawn takes
Queen takes Queen careful there's a
couple checks f2 is collapsing though
hold the Queen back to defend some
squares offering a queen exchange this a
pawn won't be able to be stopped I don't
think watch out
tricky Knight is around 25 seconds call
it even on the clock may threaten f7
he could still go in for that because in
the end the bishop has hit this is
winning for white strong night and a
pawn plus and all these squares are
covered black resigns there's nothing
stopping king h4 King takes pawn next
king is frozen where do we stand that's
a big win got two points so still made
up some ground here 106 to 93 still
catchable for sure 13 points back with
46 minutes to go next opponent okay
I missed the beginning of that one goes
so fast
alright saving upon this is a really
strong Bishop yeah there's nothing
there's nothing going on on the D file
with the Bishop end on like so so fixing
upon on a dark square maybe targeting it
targeting it at some stage improving the
King just in time before there's a pin
that could be exploited b3 the rook is
kind of trapped yeah this pawn is gonna
fall not so fast
all these squares are covered why why do
you go so passive there okay this rook
is in some serious trouble feels now now
we have this kind of stuff tracking down
the pond the a pond or the F pond look
at converge on f2 right now this guy is
fast so maybe that's why there was a
little bit of pause because this rook is
out of play you went upon but now you
have to backtrack take several moves
before the rook is back in a position
meanwhile this pawn is flying and
Carlsen will not be in time so he's
gonna have to pitch the bishop for the
pawn and hope that this guy could run
like the wind blows go go go forest yeah
it's not looking good for team black I
am opponent first time they're playing
just gonna have to hold this ground here
and just go for a draw I guess
repetition draw it is okay lucky to get
away with the draw in that position 106
to 94 clever tactic but fails still in a
game 12 points behind now who's in third
76 that's a ways back and look at
that streak 26:42 with seems to be 10
losses in a row and I I said earlier I
was going to check quickly what the
performance rating or Carlsen is in this
tournament I don't believe it's above
3000 with this with this particular
field and the several losses that he's
had for this arena
anyhow things are looking good in this
position nice queen and now this night
is going to be challenged
there's not really a wonderful square
for h2 not fun d3 is a nice square so
can you get there hmm
felt like there was a better approach
for black with those last couple of
moves okay yeah he's just gonna defend
the base points slowly improve the King
here here here here here we go keep the
rooks don't want to trade this active
rook for a dummy here on e 2 but on is
now dropping call it even on the clock
isn't the healthiest of extra pawns but
it still is an extra and the king is
gonna take up a nice post on e5 now and
the rook is gonna get look to get active
g4 there's h5 looking to get into g3 now
he's gonna go poke around a little bit
maybe going for this no rook f3 there's
wreck f2 to be very careful you don't
you have to keep pressure here oh look
at that transfer I love that
that was really nice Shack there's gonna
be met with the block by the rook in a
safeguard that pond okay the king is
gonna step up rook here maybe look at
these positions for the rooks AUSA blink
King takes pawn you got to take this now
should be a draw but with the clock
situation I would I'm thinking black is
gonna be able to manage this one we'll
see they're gonna play out this rook and
pawn endgame rook versus rook no they're
just gonna go straight in for it rook
swap and draw 108 295 another draw
neither has fire top two guys 41 minutes
to go
108 95 79 this is the first page what is
the performance rating 2958 not bad
nirvana 95 next opponent okay wow this
is intense this is this is the most
intense arena
to date for sure I mean it was a runaway
last arena by I think 70 points it was
won by 70 points between first and
second okay where are we at here even
material unopposed
where bishop trade be pawns no he's just
giving up the exchange oh that's not
that was a blunder that wasn't something
that was planned there no rook be one
and then be three yeah just had a blind
spot there as all yeah this is trouble
now King here there's this 9s to block
have to keep the rook on your toast this
isn't looking good yeah I don't even
know how you stir up some trouble
it's nice gonna get crunched soon even
push here no he'd jump in he get a
little fancy yeah taking advantage of
the pin it's just isn't a good square
though I mean yeah this happening soon
tonight is a night is trickier just a
little bit tricky if you get these moves
in you're gonna try for that maybe King
here 13 sec
12 seconds gonna try for that there is a
there is that move okay yeah it's just
safeguarding now this night is super
clumsy have resigned soon yeah
quick resign not a quick resign resign
arson goes down meanwhile clever tactic
but fail is at 1:10 with fire Carlson
has 95 still 15 back with 40 minutes to
go first prize 2,250 bucks
Holly Reza next opponent I am strong I
am
Wow it needs to get back on the on the
horse here to get the fire and a lot of
fours okay this pond will be used or can
be used at some point to break up the
kingside structure offer of a likes
light square bishop exchange d3 for the
night the hop in it happened there there
is some sacrifice on that square black
is the better side here
being up upon and having the better
pieces the night the Queen and now
picking up another pun as you want it he
does yeah
rook here the de pon could push so up
two pawns now an open file to work with
where's the knight gonna go nowhere
okay just wants to contest the only open
file
that pond was going to fall so we wanted
to split up the ponds wants to gain
something
even material-wise but this structure is
very very poor its negate the night just
trade nights two one King and pawn
endgame it's not gonna be trapped
tonight might be trapped this night is
trapped the night stay is here about how
do you attack the night oh that's how
but this King is very fast
Carlson realizes this that there's gonna
be an outside pass or soon and he needs
the night around to help defend and it
just this is just hopefully it works oh
there is a fork who's gonna be faster
they're both gonna Queen barely oh wow
okay
Oh wasn't there moved there that was
Queen here he missed that I think
I think there was an opportunity there
to win the Queen
now another draw which is good news for
clever tactic but fail who remains on
fire
96 Carlson is back 18 points who 37
minutes to go I don't know what do you
guys think here in the chat is it
possible can you come back alright GM
opponent 5 to 1 is their match score
all right
and he's going pawn hunting now yeah I
wants to inconvenience the Queen first
and only then do this because black
would be able to take be in the end so a
clean pawn in a strong
queen position now I pass her securing
the knight hmm this pawn could fall soon
now this is a strong Bishop looking at
looking to challenge that Bishop soon no
just rooks some rook activity now these
pawns are fast yeah Bishop is so strong
Knight here what do you take with the
rook and wants the bishop next three
pawns and he's gonna go in for this oh
wow what a move man Knight takes rook
pawn takes and you can't stop these two
that is super slick right there let me
tell you and he's gonna go in for this
because he has some coordination at
least but look at the clock situation 30
seconds for black this should be a draw
there is a fortress here hmm well I
believe there's even a fortress in this
position he didn't mean to drop the pawn
this isn't going well for Carlsen this
game right here he's done three seconds
to 27
Wow that was that was played so fast
this position right here to calculate
that just a3 saying God take my rook
connected passers anyhow another loss
for Carlsen 122 296 Wow
he's pulling away 34 minutes to go ali
reza next opponent I'm surprised we're
not getting that pairing a bit more I
guess the you know that they they just
aren't both not playing at the same time
okay what to do trade trade bishops no
looking to grab upon B files open up a
little tactic now on takes Knight Bishop
takes Knight counter sack on e5 in the
NC three is gonna fall after this
look at this variation Wow
even material you've lost track does it
want the rook Bishop is very important
to keep around to defend the Kings side
rook is it will take this pawn though
if available I was defended mmm now it's
winning now you will take the rook
because it's for free white resigned
okay
1:22 still on fire 98 24 points behind
ok back in another game he has to string
together a bunch of wins if he's gonna
have any chance at winning this well uh
four wins in a row with the titled
arenas
let's see you sacked upon there to make
sure black didn't establish a strong
central presence with e5 so down upon
but now White has some nice squares to
work with in particularly for the bishop
is a bit clumsy now very nice piece play
for white it's uh what this initial fee
5 move granted white he's picking up the
exchange yeah he's no up and he's up the
exchange now
how do you want to do it rook to d6 your
defend the knight allows this and the
night is still stuck you'd like to get
the bishop here how do you pull that off
ooh yeah this isn't gonna go well for oh
the Queen's gun whoops okay
another win and with that Carlson has
fire he needs to win these next like
five games oper next opponent opera
maybe with a bit more confidence now
playing against Carlsen having won his
first game in their last encounter
let's see can black get that move in
white is trying to prevent it unhealthy
C pawn C getting it in now yes Queens
will come off first no not so fast
challenging the bishop black has some
space
White has to be careful though no now
he's picking up upon the Queen will not
be trapped there's a way out and now
here comes the central majority
it's one of the areas or white you know
this could be felt being up upon that's
a central pawn presence two to one
and two to zero on the queenside to
clean ponds and perfect coordination and
just opening it up to to zero
Queen takes here if Knight takes pawn
not now those rook takes Bishop on Queen
takes g6 just returning to a cozy square
the a pawn Falls
you know some trades now now the bishop
found a beautiful square Queen f3 King G
to h4 or if available route to d7
converging on f7 Queen exchange yeah
also the clock is looking pretty good
this bishop stuck
move with the bishop you might try
something like this he's gonna oh okay
he has that
six seconds to 11 seconds
let's see he's there in time upper
resigned big win big win but he is still
26 back 132 104 okay twelve teen next
opponent who is now in 13th place last
time we saw 12 teen at in a fifth place
this is gonna be tough to catch I don't
know if he could do it that is a big gap
with really not a lot of time to go only
29 minutes to go in this tournament
being back 20-plus points that's a lot
Knight takes pawn there's 93 and the
bishop Falls White knows that and
resigns pretty quick win 108 134 to 108
he definitely needs to make a run right
now in a a beefy opponent Rebecca Harris
took second in the last title arena now
in 8th in this tournament we'll try to
play against this guy rook here and
there's some tricks okay one rook
exchange or not yes the bishop runs the
risk of getting trapped on this kind of
stuff with B 6 and then hunting down the
bishop get away with taking the pawn
ok 1 huh structure going to be repaired
no it's not control the knight doesn't
want to do that so a minor piece
specific ending can you target this guy
and try to win that now you just go into
a self-penned he's going to try to win
this on opposite colored Bishop ending
here here take out the knight take here
that wouldn't be an opposite colored
Bishop bending anyhow black is now up
upon a very valuable one
hasser a past h-bomb can't get these
guys rolling this pawn would drop
given time he's gonna get it rolling
another pond has just fallen yeah
no these these pieces are coordinating
it really well and it's a clear path all
these squares are covered gonna play
this one out yeah yeah he's got this one
Carlson has this one and a resigned 138
okay we're gonna get that pairing 138 to
112 they both just finished I saw it
change 138 to 112 this is a must-win
I think we're getting this pairing now
doctor drunken Stein number two versus
clever tactic but fail here we go three
thousand eight to twenty nine forty
eight let's see a benoni on board
Wow quick
f5 this is a sensitive square especially
now without the light square Bishop is
on board but can white make use of that
square can't really pivot at that point
just secure this first no he's going in
for some there's something exciting
happening over here black has a lot of
pieces targeting the kingside and a
pivot point mmm he's just looking to
undermine the night
this is defended black has an excellent
position here and white is going into
the think tank who went upon he wants it
and he doesn't want the night the night
is kind of dead anyhow taking out the
b-pawn now this guy's past uh tough day
at the office for the night on each one
white doesn't even have to do anything
all the pieces are on wonderful squares
and he could just slowly improve over
here on the queenside
it trade down a bunch as well or take
advantage of this pin that's what we're
having huh tough to defend you can't
play here the knight is there just
resigned that's a huge win
138 116 that was a must-win he's now
back 22 points needs to go on a run here
Astana chess
twenty four twenty fourth place third
game Carroll Khan on board okay think
this bishops going to struggle some okay
I have time to get in b6 Bishop b7 let's
see
Bishop return pointing up the king and
look to dislodge the night with c4
challenge this strong post that's where
we have where's the night going also now
that g6 has been played these squares a
week and may thread on h6 careful Knight
here is no good take the knight Knight
h6 mate how do you defend this mate
o f6 gone
down upon and this is crunched Bishop is
hip and you could just turn into a
trading machine here Bishop takes Bishop
first unleashing an attack against the
bishop Bishop takes Bishop Bishop takes
Knight Bishop takes pawn first ah fancy
Bishop takes Queen takes pawn with check
and then you get the piece back black
resigned another big win 141 20 clever
tactic won the next game but is not in a
game we're gonna get that pairing again
I believe we're gonna get that pairing
again we do okay
another huge game if he's if Carlsen is
going to come back he's got a knock this
this clever tactic but fail off again
let's see Roy Lopez hmm let's see how
this one plays out oh man this is a huge
game 24 minutes left in the tournament
it is possible to still catch number one
but this is a must-win and you just won
upon Bishop back there's a disconnect
between the rooks up upon Carlsen is up
upon let's see how this is converted
just anchoring in the night there 36
seconds a nice time edge as well
let's see this pond gonna fall give up h
to g3 ooh hang on got a fork there
things are just going way too crazy for
me to keep up with here Queen takes d5
what is not hanging here which rook is
not hanging oh man
okay in the end there's there should be
something oh that's a nice in-betweener
look at that in-betweener right there
bishop takes before taking the bishop
here
okay opposite color bishops he doesn't
even take the bishop he wants two
connected passers that was beautiful how
do you stop these ponds that was nice
that was real nice he's gonna be up the
exchange now this is a win also down
tents down to under 10 seconds clever
tactic he resigned another huge win
Carlsen going up for clever tactic but
fail not on fire only 16 points back now
four more wins you could get four more
wins in eight minutes there's still 22
minutes to go oh man this is intense I
have not been able to look at the chat
okay next opponent mud Pro can't slip up
if he's got to win this one - he's got
to get this one could damage the white
structure but don't forget this is the
good bishop or a bad Bishop exchange so
somehow white would like to play against
the bishop on b7 Queen g3 mm-hmm once
the pawn here maybe once this and an
attack against h7 yeah
what like has to be very careful and hmm
is there really anything here for white
I don't see how you get a rook in there
in time I think the bishop and Queen are
not enough in this position Oh
is this working he gave up the bishop
just to allow rook to f3 pivot and says
take my rook I don't care I want to give
me thirty three seconds is there defense
here he's ready to pack up and run no
that's me whoa okay a pretty quick win
and okay no no that was still the last
game clever tactic but fails still in
the game 128 for Carlson 12 point back
12 point I don't even put the S at the
end of that one that's how intense
that's 12 point back 12 point backs let
me create that username 12 point back
anyhow go Kirk on next opponent in 15th
place ah man this is a lot of fun this
is a lot of fun we got a race we got a
race white is also up a piece Oh go Kirk
on berserk by the way this is gonna be
another win in a pretty fast one is it
gonna be over soon
no reason
two's dropping yeah
Oh God pick your favorite thing to do
here yeah where's the mate we got to
resign and with that 140 to 132 oh man
this is so Ted's okay clever tactic but
fail has he rebounded he got a game in
there
Carlson is not yet in a game under 20
minutes to go
MSB to next opponent okay let's see
Wow so intense queens are off this night
is having a little bit of trouble and
white is better here and have some some
stuff to target no oh why is he pausing
because of this here yeah that's why
that Knight f5 move was gonna be very
strong so because of this Knight f5 idea
that's what gave pause that's that's
what made white pause there but now you
got to watch off your mates it has the
mates no it's not quite mate you need
something control here
not quite mate meanwhile White has to be
a little bit careful
Hall fancy
that was fancy right there here just
guarding this square black has maybe
some mating ideas as well
be a little bit careful a check another
check where do you want to give check
don't get mated and then you have this
all he wants rook f7 rook f7 with check
Knight check these pawns are pushing
through you can't give me to the king
White's gonna get this one they could
keep pushing the King is secure look at
that pond he's amazing
white is there in time yep sack the
Queen for the pond and runny pond there
you go
ten seconds called eleven seconds easy
I'm gonna get another win there it is
white wins 144 136 eight points back
both with fire not paired up though ali
reza next opponents 17 minutes to go
homeboy hmm this is a blast
here comes e5 like has that supported
now what to do with the night alright
focusing in on c5 this pawn is either
gonna capture push or at some point
black at capture and grant the knight
access to c5 okay as squares given up
the king knight also likes that square
as well so both can take up some nice
posts it's gonna jump into d for
beautiful coordination here nice piece
play this pawn is restricting the night
so no recapturing with the piece and now
they're just jumping in and i'm gonna be
up the exchange and you can take the
bishop out yeah it's a clean exchange
this night is very poor piece
f-for right now or with some prep work
little prep work
multi-purpose hit the pawn prep f4 and
just peel open the F file Queen has a
responsibility now white is granting the
knight access to d5 and to be a little
bit annoying this Knight here
get the King out of the way at least one
of the checks mmm this is a strong night
careful now careful now hmm you get away
with that huh
no this pawn Oh pawn pawn push you take
the knight might have to take and then
go here just in time
okay this is good for routine black he
will be there in time Bishop is gonna
get a lot of pawns though you want the
King around to stop this prawn and then
the rook had active a clock situation
good for team black could take the pawn
now the bishop was blocked getting over
just in time King takes pawn its mate
okay should be able to get this three
seconds two seconds one second you could
take yeah he's gonna get this one on the
clock point zero two not enough okay
another big win and with that 144 140
Carlsen with fire and clever tactic but
fail slipped up is that he opera got him
not in a game yet four points back Wow
he caught him he's within four fifteen
minutes to go
can he now start to well he still has to
get even can you get this next win in
there and then start to build a lead
we're gonna see not in a game yet
bathroom break as I would ease bathroom
break no pairing
first place two thousand two hundred
fifty bucks five hundred two hundred 125
75 50 still not in the game still not in
the game
what are we getting here no game is it
really about to break I don't know he
did he is passe it was a bathroom break
I called it
wow what a call I was totally blind to
that oh that was a pretty quick bathroom
break Gosselin I don't know
anyhow nobody I don't know I don't know
okay it's even why why are you taking
like that oh there would have been a win
of a piece so now you have to be content
with a completely crunched inside
structure and black is up to ponds big
problems for MSB to see one is under
control you could chop and then chop
here there we go
or that way two minor pieces for the
rook as long as this pawn doesn't become
past its golden for team black in black
has perfect coordination this pawn isn't
going anywhere
Bishop will superglue the the pawn in
there just finding good squares for the
pieces
the bishop tonight's getting a little
bit too crazy maybe he wants the king to
play as well it's nothing to do for
white meanwhile black can slowly improve
the quality of all pawns there goes the
a pond and now it's the be pond who has
passed lack is winning this no issue on
the clock three miners versus the rook
and the rook is actually dead there's no
returning here two Knights are too much
no resign it's gonna play it on out
carlson is getting this one is well how
many wins in a row is this for Carlsen
what a comeback this is no stalemates
made on board back to terment 148 144
still with a four point lead 12 minutes
to go both have fire clever tactic but
fails in a game oper now against Carlsen
looking for an e5 break C form F pawn
moves C pawn in there this diagonal is
now open towards the King let's see yeah
white hit first this was a well-timed c4
c4 one move later and maybe it's black
who has an initiative after e5 so now
there's some squares that white can work
with E 4 E 5 even material-wise but
white is for choice here having the very
nice squares doing Knight comparison
this is a fantastic knight on e4 now
targeting this point he falls this pawn
runs like crazy
this Knight is having a tough time
Knight c5 Knight c5 would be a nice move
as well
Knight is finding a good square but this
pawn is now gone could get that pawn
though that wasn't playing what's this
oh that's sweet look at that
killer bishops and a pin that is very
uncomfortable how do you get out of this
pin oh man how do you get out of this
pin here we go not not so fast you have
to get the King out of this first King
here and then f5 look at the time that's
coming off the clock here King here and
now f5 is the threat taking advantage of
the pin there's no way out the rook is
gone resigns and with that 151 48
how to draw clever tactic but fail had a
draw does not have fire with this win
right here Carlson could take the lead
for the first time in the tournament
with ten minutes to go the first time
he's possibly in first right here let's
see playing against Gawain Jones wow
this is intense
alright Kings Indian defense it's a race
position same sights castling black is
going for mate white is looking for
these positional features this is a
super invasive pond white is now hiding
behind it does not want to take okay
what's the plan here how do you get at
the White King meanwhile what are you
doing about these pounds pushing through
for for a queen
he's got a queen and what next
this is collapsing for black big-time
down a rook killer Knight what does the
Queen do is to give up another night
yeah dominoes these Knights are bouncing
ooh one of them just fell but there is
Bishop c3 Bishop c3 there's Knight g3
careful
oh he that's what he calculated it he
said that it's okay because he can run
out here that's why there was a pause no
forget about that the Queen is there is
that oh that was just one of the many
things I missed okay he got it win where
does that play some first place with 8
minutes 38 seconds to go and clever
tactic but failed lost against 12 teen
national master 12 teen is no joke the
warning next opponent they've played
this position before if I'm recalling
correctly
caro-kann on board 8 minutes 20 seconds
two-point lead for Carlsen can he now
extend this lead he's been Hana terror
how many wins in a row
was this I said it a little a while back
when there was maybe like 40 minutes to
go
that he needed to go on a winning streak
and he started going with a streak
things are looking good in this position
are we gonna have d5
let's see some space with the pawns I
try for that no case he has a square for
the bishop he's down on time he has a
square on c5 I think you want to keep
one rook around yeah this is a position
where you want to keep one rook around
if it just becomes night versus bishop
that's hard for black to win doesn't
have the correct harmony between
structure and Bishop and now there's
something to target that's the other
thing
keep one rook on the board and this pawn
that has great depth you know you one
day he could really become a beast and
it's becoming a beast it's a it's a win
black just won and has extended the lead
to four seven minutes to go Carlson has
fire and has strung together call it
something like a dozen games in a row
he's in another game here it is mud Pro
six minutes 53 seconds to go in this
Leach has titled arena for Queens off
all right let's see where the pieces
fall
[Music]
interesting you take the rook and then
take here so now this rook is very
clumsy the knight will be flushed away
this is an excellent square for the
knight cannot be challenged by a bishop
might try for this at some stage here we
go
Knight here okay can you make some
progress on this stage or on this side
of the board hmm probably didn't want to
give up that night I think he wanted to
go here this wasn't there in time so the
bishop controls the knight and black is
grabbing some space in the Kings side
and this pawn might drop I like this g4
and then get the King over here on g5
and that restricts the knight okay he's
doing it similar just doesn't want to
push the pawn now he has something to
attack target this and now this pawn is
passed and this rook has an
uncomfortable job of defending okay
Carlsen does not care about these pawns
at this stage he just wants to push on
through with the Jeep on and with that
white resigns these pawns are just way
too much and the night is very clumsy
being attacked at the moment 161 54 both
with fire are they gonna get paired up I
think they're gonna get paired up this
is a big game if they get paired up this
is this is huge both with fire five
minutes 11 seconds in the tournament
tournament standings 161 54 both have
fire are we going to get a game
we are getting a game not that pairing
though still has to win this game has to
keep winning we're only gonna get a few
more games in here
Carlson slips and clever tactic but fail
wins that's a big that's a big change
Carlson would lose fire clever tactic
would fail would go up before that just
wants to know he's giving up upon our
blundering up on or okay he's defending
the rook the knight is gonna be kicked
soon okay the rooks are off Carlson will
have very nice active rooks okay now
he's just getting the pawn right back
better for team black winning or bet
better for team white I should say pass
tape on incoming you could insert f4 you
want or just keep running with the a
pawn now now the rooks are off and this
Knight is a long ways away from
defending the rook pawns Knights hate
trying to defend bishop check oh no
you're just taking the knight pays up a
piece oh this is looking good as long as
there's not some Mouse lip I don't
I don't anticipate any Mouse lip yeah
plenty of ways to do it 20 seconds this
pawn is now following we're gonna have
resign no resign they're gonna play this
one out trade bishops
just push the pawn all the way through
and you know stalemates and and as long
as there's no stalemates it's a mate in
a few check amen checkmate
big win 164 and I think that's doing it
that win right there coupled with a loss
by clever tactic but fail with or
against oper that's going to seal it
eight point gap with only three minutes
to go he did it a 4-pete for Carlsen
can't catch him at that point the
warning one of the last games in this
tournament
wow what a comeback what was it at some
point twenty four points back in this
tournament he was oh man this was
incredible to to observe Wow
really incredible this isn't a good
position for black by the way but I
think he could afford this loss at this
stage these pawns are just so great and
white as targets he might resign I also
might resign and just try to get in one
more game no it's not resigning it's a
big problem this pawn is now passed whoa
what's that about
I just wants to push on through huh here
black is prepared to sack it's just
gonna run Wow each side oh that's fancy
don't even take the rook
oh but hang on this pond is gonna
promote with check one minute thirty
seconds in this tournament okay a queen
for Carlson Carlson resigns he will not
be stopped he now has a nine point lead
with one minutes ago let's see this
final game against nirvana the likely
final game nirvana 95 can he go out with
a win let's see Wow I
want to take a look at this this string
of wins Carlson put together to pull off
a fourth leech has titled arena for
victory a 2250 prize for first I don't
even know who's gonna be in third I was
so fixated on the one in two spots this
whole time that MSB too has been up
there quite a bit not sure how far back
Rebecca Harris was anyhow let's see the
conclusion wow this was intense you know
he can't go pawn hunting because of
Bishop to b7 now he will fall and this
is simple or black picking up to clean
ponds and an ideal placement or a rook
now that's game over a resign and that's
gonna do it zero on the tournament clock
there you have it
dr. drunken Stein that game didn't count
for the tournament that final one their
first place dr. drunken Stein with a
3012 performance rating second place
clever tactic but fail no idea who that
is
2972 performance doctor drunken Stein
168 clever tactic but fail 160 and then
a drop off knight King in there 129
upper 116 nirvana 95 108 and MSB to 108
those six all walk away with something
in their pocket 2254 first 504 second
204 third 125 75 60 who else is on the
first page
gm's and IIMs AIIMS that should be GM's
soon enough
that's your first page 270 participants
in all
it's penguin you guys are telling me oh
really
this was the slippery penguin huh
he created a new account just for this
tournament is that what I'm hearing in
the chat Wow
fancy what a run if that's if that's
true there and from what you're telling
me in the chat okay let me go through
the pages here here is page 212 teen
coming in 17th place top finisher for
the NMS in this tournament fantastic
here's page 3 page 4 5 let's just zip
right through here I want to just show
all of them here that's how you know
it's a strong field just need just one
quick example Astana chess fantastic
player 50 first place
beefy beastly field let's go through
them all not sure why it's flickering
exactly like this all right let's see
this was I think the most number of
participants for the titled arena let's
see not quite there yeah and there's
penguin gee there's the penguin he
hopped in and then apparently wanted to
go a bit stealthy for this tournament
clever tactic but fail that's everybody
that was competing or not really
competing in some cases
wow what a tournament and what a
comeback
what was this final stretch he lost that
game against that French GM and then
after that that you know that position
where he go into that game real quick
this position here this fancy move maybe
this really set set to Carlson off after
black pulled off this move right here a3
saying take my rook because these guys
are gonna push through now he went into
a think here about a seven-second think
and from that point on he said you know
what I'm gonna kick it into a higher
gear and what was that gear exactly he
went super crazy strong fast winning one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 counting
for the tournament and then one more at
the end call it a 20-game winning streak
in the end to take first place what a
what a tournament
clever tactic but fail what a run man
awesome
this was great this was a lot of fun to
observe
you